good evening I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight the
monster they created that's the focus of
tonight's
angle Biden's chances for re-election
are nose diving and his campaign is
getting very nervous CNN describes the
uneasiness that many Democrats feel
about a president whose age is twice his
approval rating and this from axios
describing how private polls show the
same hurdle as public ones
brutally low popularity on the topics
that matter most to voters now Biden's
getting crushed on his handling of
immigration crime and inflation it's not
death by one issue but by a half dozen
at once and it gets worse because he's
even managing to alienate his strongest
voting blocks his unwavering support for
Israel which has been America's policy
for many decades even during their
bloody counter offensive against Hamas
is turning off a big chunk of both
younger voters and is also at odds with
many African-American voters a recent
quinc poll found that 51% of Voters
under 35 say they disapprove of the
United States sending weapons and
Military Support to Israel that's a much
higher figure than the 28% of Americans
who oppose such a policy now the CBS
News poll conducted earlier was even
worse for Biden 59% of respondents under
30 said the US should not send weapons
and supplies to Israel and for those
between the ages of 30 and 44 64% said
the US should not now these age groups
were key to Biden's re-election election
in 2020 and given these and other
terrible signs for the administration
it's about time someone asked Joe's
understudy a tough question a recent CBS
poll found that at the beginning of
President Biden's term 70% of young
people people under 30 said he was doing
a good job MH now it's less than
50% why is that if you pull how young
people feel about the climate and the
warming of our planet it pulls as one of
their top concerns the challenge that we
have as an Administration is we got to
let people know who BR it to them that's
our challenge but it is not that the
work we are doing is not very very
popular with a lot of people now think
about what vice president cackles is
saying there people are super happy but
they just don't know how super happy
they are wow speaking of being in denial
the world is on fire one would argue Joe
Biden just went into a second
extremely difficult hot war zone and
dealt with world leaders sat in on a war
cabinet meeting in Israel is able to
navigate relationships that he has
developed over decades and yet it's
going to be close between these two guys
now the man in 2 and a half years took
us from peace and prosperity to war and
inflation and over at MSNBC they're
shocked that he's not soaring in the
polls huh now of course the Press is
just mad that their narrative didn't
stick because during the tussle over the
speaker race of course they hammered the
Republicans that they're hopelessly
divided that theme went on and on but
the truth is the real Discord is between
Democrat voters and Democrat policies
especially on the war issue which the
publication Vox cites as Biden's major
vulnerability the perception of Biden's
ownership of this war will only grow as
Israel expands and extends its Siege of
Gaza that's bad for Biden's electability
with so many young American voters
increasingly critical of his unfettered
backing of
Israel now who makes up the Democrats
anti-israel anti-war Coalition well many
of the same types of Voters who went
door too for Joe in Wisconsin in
Michigan and Pennsylvania that's who I
feel like that whatever Hamas did was
for a good cause to get back our land we
know that the Palestinian people have
been so resilient in the face of many
invasions like this and and we hope um
and that that Palestine will continue um
to fight for their right to be
free many
us how manys did you K
[Music]
today now for years now the Democrats
have been trying to hold together what's
ultimately an unwieldy Coalition of the
old Clinton types who are always eager
for US military action and the
anti-American lefties that we saw in the
summer of 2020 and now once again in the
Pro Hamas protests across the US the
current situation in the Middle East is
straining that Coalition in ways that
could cost Biden enormously in
2024 Trump who's stun staunchly
pro-israel but still a pragmatist on
foreign policy is already pulling some
young voters from Biden Republicans they
should not bail of course bail out the
Democrats by nominating a candidate who
would just Greenlight the funding of not
one not two but three Wars at one time
why create a political escape hatch for
the democ R by doing that I say let them
instead face what they themselves
created a Frankenstein Coalition of
anti-American anti-israel and
anti-semitic Fanatics and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else